[Musique]
sauce de poisson sauce aux huîtres
Eysines tamari même la très connue sauce
soya se décline en différentes variétés
sur les tablettes d'épicerie ou dans les
boutiques spécialisées on trouve de plus
en plus de sauce
de soya peut amener différentes côtés de
Salé si on regarde certains Soyaux qui
beaucoup plus salés donc là on va jouer
justement à équilibrer avec d'autres
types de assaisonnements
après ça il y a certains soyas qui ont
des épices dedans et comme ici on
regarde c'est marqué extrait de reclus
ici on peut voir qu'il y a de la sauce
soya qui est complètement pure
en cuisine les Chinois adoptent bien
souvent une sauce soya et ils yiennent
c'est celui que j'ai appris à utiliser
beaucoup je connais le niveau de sel
là-dedans je suis pas obligé de le peser
je sais des gens en partant à peu près
comment qui va saler alors je prends ça
j'en mets un petit peu c'est fait après
ça on me demande c'est quoi la meilleure
sauce soya il y en a pas assez ça dépend
vraiment comment ce que qu'on utilise
tes habitudes est-ce que tu sale
beaucoup si on sale moins on pourrait
aller chercher justement un soya qui a
moins sodium dedans
toutes les sauces soya contiennent du
blé et certaines sont plus foncées le
sauce soja foncée c'est un ajout de
mélasse alors qui fait que ça devient
plus épais plus foncé
sucré aussi un petit peu sucré vraiment
pour colorer les animaux
la version japonaise de la sauce soya et
la tamari ce qui est intéressant dans le
tamari c'est 100% soya et le fait que ce
soit quasiment 100% soya on dit que
c'est un soya qui est sans gluten la
tamari c'est un petit peu plus léger je
dirais c'est plus doux comparativement à
la sauce soya chinois
alors à chacun de trouver la sauce soya
qui lui convient
proche parente de la sauce soya la
huissin
de la sauce soya s'est fait à base de
soya mais on ajoute de l'ail dépendante
des sortes on ajoute du miel ou bien du
sucre alors il y a salé mais il y a du
parfumé il y a du sucré dedans alors
c'est un bon mélange
Eric étudiant en cuisine et d'origine
laotienne ils mettent en valeur une
sauce à Poutine en y incorporant de la
sauce haïtine
c'est vraiment réussi c'est justement le
signe qui vient aussi apporter ce goût
sucré un peu un peu fumé barbecue aussi
justement on peut dire c'est un
croisement quand la vie rencontre le
Québec dans la poutine
ingrédient qui vient rehausser la
poutine d'Eric et la sauce de poisson un
ingrédient cher à Cogne qui est
originaire du Vietnam la sauce de
poisson ça vient envelopper le tout pour
avoir une équivalent de la sauce Poutine
classique mais revisité avec le soleil
de Lorient
pour ce chef enseignant la source de
poisson et le Grand Cru des sauces
asiatiques c'est quand on regarde les
listes ingrédients une sauce de poisson
c'est seulement poisson au sel point
alors si vous trouvez ça ce poisson avec
ces trois ingrédients là ça c'est
parfait la sauce de poisson pure la
serra qu'on mange à table ça sert
surtout pour mariner pour faire une
aglaçage ou bien pour cuisiner surtout à
table il faut le manger dilué c'est une
fois une portion de sauce de poisson
pour 8 portions d'eau et c'est ça le
ratio le plus pertinent quand on met 8 x
2 alors ça devient vraiment un bon goût
balancé entre le salé et puis la
légèreté d'une sauce qu'on peut avoir le
mot qui revient souvent une amie sucrée
salée profondeur
il n'y a pas de piquant dedans mais
vraiment une profondeur on sent la mer
vraiment quelque chose qui est vraiment
qui appétissant qui est qui est
mystérieux et invitant à revenir aussi
produit populaire la sauce aux huîtres
qu'on
utilise dans les marinades ou pour
badigeonner contrairement aux autres
sources utilisées par nos chefs la sauce
aux huîtres n'est pas fermentée
la sauce aux huîtres qui est aussi un
consistance un peu comme la sauce way
sin aussi beaucoup retrouver dans la
cuisine cantonais mais c'est souvent
pour faire des sautés pour faire mariner
des trucs
on a une sauce qui est assez épais qui
peut être utilisé pour saler mais c'est
moins neutre que la sauce soya
j'utilise la sauce d'huile dans mes
plats pour dire à qui on veut quelque
chose d'un peu plus haut de gamme
parce que justement ça ajoute un peu
nous mamie ça rallonge les saveurs ça
donne vraiment un beau croquant au lait
dessus
[Musique]
j'ai goûté
ensuite dans les piments prêts aller
avec celui qui est juste un peu de glacé
avec soya
on est le goût de sel en bouche
soya tout de suite à coller dessus sur
les piments c'est tout simple juste avec
un peu de gingembre
toutes ces sauces asiatiques on leur
rôle en cuisine à chacun d'expérimenter
pour arriver au goût recherché la
cuisine asiatique c'est un cuisine très
démocratique dans le sens que le chef
c'est pas lui qui le décideur suprême du
goût du client alors il fait un plat et
puis la sauce soja est sur la table le
ruissier n'est sur la table alors le
client il peut prendre le plat que et
fait par le chef avec amour puis on
prend les personnaliser avec les goûts
qu'on veut
tellement de choses à dire que ça va
prendre des heures à parler de ça
ensemble avec une bière
[Musique]